تسريبات من اروقه البنتاغون الى العالم
كشفت عما تخططه امريكا كما كشفت اختراق
احدى عشر دوله بدءا من الصين الى هايتي في
هذه الوثيقه ما يدل على ان الصين تحت
المجهر تتجسس امريكا على عدوتها اللدود
فهنا وثائق تضمنت تحليلا للمخاطر الصينيه
واسعه النطاق واستعداد بكين لارسال
مساعدات فتاكه الى روسيا وتفاصيل اختبار
تجريبي لصاروخ نووي يفوق سرعه الصوت
تسريبات كشفت ايضا ان امريكا تمارس ضغوطا
على كوريا الجنوبيه في حثها لارسال
مساعدات عسكريه الى اوكرانيا في وقت تتخوف
سول من غضب موسكو وثيقه اخرى كشفت مساعي
اسرائيل لتزويد اوكرانيا بنظام دفاع جوي
سبايدر سام اضافه الى صواريخ جافل المضاده
للدروع بينما يتضح هنا ان روسيا ستزود
ايران بط 35 ونظام دفاع جوي وقدرات
صاروخيه الوثيقه عرجت ايضا على قلق
اسرائيل الشديد من التقارب العسكري بين
روسيا وايران مجموعه فاجنال الروسيه
طالتها نار التسريبات ايضا فضحت احدى
الوثائق مخططه فاجنر للسفر الى هايتي
والتعاون رسميا مع عصابات مسلحه متهمه
بقضايا قتل واختطاف مسلسل التسريبات لا
تزال تحليلاته مستمره عالميا ما يضع
الولايات المتحده امام حرج سياسي وعسكري
قد يغير الحسابات مستقبلا غذاء السالم
العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات